[Music]
what the [ __ ] do you do to courtney to
make her so happy
honestly at the beginning we were like
wait are they
i'm still thinking that hooking up
if it was like that kind of relationship
yeah they went there
it's never a dull moment kim kardashian
and her famous fam
just gave addison ray the third degree
about her friendship with kourtney
kardashian
we all decided to get to the bottom of
courtney and addison
so we invited addison over for lunch but
without courtney
because we just want to ask a couple
questions and get to know her more
around a little bit in attendance at
this extremely awkward lunch
courtney's ex and the father of her
three children scott disick
kris jenner kendall jenner kim and khloe
kardashian
and they totally grill the tick tock
star
wait so where are you from what's your
story so you're from louisiana
when did you move here um december
so do you live with your parents have
you ever been arrested
what's your blood type what is your
credit score do you have siblings
oh my god you guys are you interrogating
this poor girl
yeah and it doesn't stop there what the
f
do you do to courtney to make her so
happy honestly at the beginning we were
like wait
are they i'm still thinking that
hooking up if it was like that kind of
relationship
that was the elephant in the room if
they were no we're not
it's okay if you are no we're not nobody
judges
but it is funny no it's just very weird
that that's what the
impression was yeah for just like two
seconds
i would say like four and in a teaser
released
last week looks like we'll see even more
investigative work as kim and chloe try
to crack the code on all things courtney
and addison
add addison ray is a tick tocker
she sleeps over a lot what room does she
sleep in my mom's
and naturally looks like we'll see some
tick tock dancing too
courtney's not really like this with her
other girlfriends
the 41 year old reality star and the 20
year old social media star became
friends
last year amid the pandemic i love
courtney and chris so much
and the two have given fans a sneak peek
at all their fun on social media
first they collabed on a fitness video
for push
i start feeling it so much on the fire
hydrants like my side butt is just
burning good thing i did not do but
yesterday
then they recreated an iconic scene from
keeping up
i mean i feel fine i just cry myself to
sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal they even
took a trip together to palm springs
where they had a poolside photo shoot
and filmed
what else tic tac videos
[Music]
when e.t caught up with addison in
september she dished on their friendship
courtney and i just happened to have a
great friendship which is
really fun and she's been a great person
to have in my life
and she played coy when asked if she
would ever make an appearance on the hit
reality show
is there a chance that you will appear
on keeping up
with the kardashians um
i don't know who knows what the future
holds so you wouldn't say no
they were like we roll the cameras um i
feel like i'm really not a person to say
no to anything at any time ever